la storia che vi starà per raccontare
una storia molto personale diciamo
proprio una storia autobiografica che in
fondo in un certo senso la storia della
mia famiglia
in generale però potrebbe essere anche
quella delle vostre e in assoluto un
pochino la storia del nostro essere
umani
le protagoniste della mia storia sono
queste due signore che vedete di spalle
quella di destra mia mamma 81 anni
quella di sinistra mia figlia che ne ha
7 ma a volte per quello che dice sembra
che ne abbia anche più di 81 e un giorno
un giorno bimba mi ha chiesto papà ma
noi da dove veniamo
il caso vuole che fossero di ritorno un
anno fa più o meno da un viaggio e ci
trovavamo all'aeroporto internazionale
di addis abeba che più importante
crocevia del traffico aereo africano
oggi addis abeba una particolarità e
luogo dove al museo nazionale c'è
l'esemplare del nostro antenato forse
più antico di quello che potrebbe essere
uno dei nostri antenati diretti più
antichi ed aver avuto una postura bipede
questa è lucy un esemplare di
australopiteco scoperto nel 1974 non
paleoantropologo donaldson e dai suoi
collaboratori che risale a 3,2 milioni
di anni fa e negli anni scoprendo altri
reperti di questo nostro lontanissimo
antenato abbiamo scoperto che verrà
probabilmente uno dei primi a camminare
su due zampe però la nostra storia
comincia da un periodo un pochino più
recente in realtà altro colpo di fortuna
se si vuole forse una vuole appunto che
io qualche anno fa abbia partecipato al
progetto genographics della national
geographic society
in che cosa consiste il progetto
genographics in un tentativo di
ricostruire la mappa delle migrazioni
umane attraverso l'analisi del dna di
quante più persone possibile a oggi
hanno partecipato circa 800 mila persone
in che cosa consiste si manda un
campione della propria saliva fino a
washington di viene analizzato e
attraverso 750.000 marcatori sul nostro
dna
si cerca di risalire alle variazioni
alle mutazioni del dna che hanno fatto
sì che si differenzia che si
differenziassero 70 mila anni
in cui homo sapiens ha colonizzato il
mondo le diverse popolazioni umane
attraverso il lavoro del genio grafico
oggi si è ricostruita questa mappa che
in realtà porta dalla zona da cui è
partito a mozzate as quasi 70 mila anni
fa che è proprio la zona non proprio
magari quella esattamente del dis abeba
ma nel corno d'africa
da queste parti dove homo sapiens ha
cominciato a migrare a migrare verso
nord e nel giro di più di 50.000 anni
arrivare a colonizzare anche l'estremita
meridionale delle americhe ci sono
volute 50.000 anni perché occupassimo
tutto il mondo attraverso il genio
grafica è stato possibile ricostruire da
una parte la mia linea paterna quella
che ereditiamo sempre per parte di padre
per cui purtroppo le signore non lo
possono fare
la linea paterna quella che realizziamo
per partecipate attraverso il cromosoma
y che hanno soltanto i maschi
dall'altra parte attraverso il dna
mitocondriale che ereditiamo soltanto
dalla madre è stata ricostruita la
storia di quella signora che mi facevo
vedere prima la storia che comincia qui
per l'appunto circa 67 mila anni fa in
africa centrale quando l'homo sapiens
moderno comincia a migrare da questa
regione è intorno a 60 mila anni fa si
trova ad attraversare la penisola del
sinai dove un gruppo una di queste
popolazioni individuata proprio
attraverso questi marcatori genetici si
sposta attraverso la penisola del sinai
e comincia a passare in parte nella
penisola arabica nel medio oriente e ea
spostarsi un pochino verso l'anatolia in
turchia un po verso nord nel caucaso e
in parte verso l'asia a est poco più
avanti questi i discendenti di questo
gruppo continuano a spostarsi in parte
di nuovo verso nord e ancora verso est
siamo a 55 mila anni fa circa intorno a
40.000 anni fa si differenzia un'altra
popolazione che è quella che da una
parte prende direttamente la strada
della turchia per arrivare per arrivare
in europa e dall'altra invece fa la
strada più lunga attraversa il caucaso e
comincia a colonizzare la parte
settentrionale dell'europa che cosa
succede che 20.000 anni fa con l'arrivo
della glaciazione quelli che avevano
colonizzato la parte settentrionale
l'europa si spostano un pochino verso
sud e cominciano colonizzare regioni più
miti l'italia la spagna e allo stesso
tempo anche l'inghilterra che ha un
clima sicuramente piu mite del resto del
nord europa che cosa succede la storia è
finita qui no la storia di fatto la
rivediamo a ritroso perché attraverso
tutta questa serie di passaggi che
definiscono la migrazione di tutta la
mia linea materna
abbiamo superato una serie di punti che
sono fondamentali o comunque che sono
cruciali anche questi un po di colpi di
fortuna per immaginare come siamo
arrivati fino a noi in pianura padana io
sono milanese
partendo da un luogo sperduto nel
continente africano 70 mila anni fa
uno dei primi posti se ricominciamo a
ripercorrere questa strada a ritroso
dove siamo passati è più o meno quella
calare al confine tra l'italia l'austria
dove c'è il ghiacciaio del similaun dove
qualche anno fa è stato scoperto si
l'uomo dei ghiacci ice man come lo
volete chiamare questa figura
mummificata perfettamente mantenuta per
più di 5000 anni all'interno dei
ghiacciai alpini e che con il disgelo
dei ghiacciai è riapparsa la superficie
e di cui abbiamo avuto talmente tante
testimonianze da poter immaginare come
vivessere nostri predecessori europei
circa 5000 anni fa
quest'uomo si sa che è morto in
circostanze bizzarre e stato verificato
che aveva una punta di freccia
conficcata nella spalla sinistra che
probabilmente quella che ha causato il
decesso
però si sono trovate le armi che usava
per cacciare gli abiti tutto quanto per
cui siamo riusciti in qualche modo a
ricostruire l'idea che i nostri antenati
di qualche migliaio di anni fa facessero
una durissima vita tra pianura le
colline e le montagne dell'italia
settentrionale e che fosse fossero
soprattutto ancora grandi cacciatori se
risaliamo un pochino più a nord ci
ritroviamo in questa zona qua della
germania a lipsia per la precisione al
max planck institut per l'antropologia
evolutiva qui c'è questo signore che si
chiama svante pelo e che è uno dei più
grandi studiosi di genetica delle
popolazioni attraverso l'analisi
il dna quello che amano è un calco di un
cranio di neanderthal perché lui ha
sequenziato attraverso i pochi resti di
cui disponiamo il genoma dell'uomo di
neanderthal per scoprire una cosa
fondamentale che mi sono ritrovato
tranquillamente nel mio nella mia linea
materna e il fatto che una parte del
nostro genoma lo abbiamo ereditato del
nostro genoma di europei lo abbiamo
ereditato dall'uomo di neanderthal
mediamente il 2,1 per cento
il mio dna e per il 2 per cento
neandertaliano nel periodo in cui n'è
andata hanno convissuto con homo sapiens
più o meno tra 60 mila e 40.000 anni fa
quando in e anderson scomparsi homo
sapiens è un uomo di neanderthal si sono
incrociati ma non basta
pare che l'uomo sapiens si è incrociato
anche con un altro mini de abbastanza
bizzarro perché non ne sappiamo nulla
abbiamo fatto solo una scoperta nelle
carbone in una grotta delle montagne
dell'alta e tra russia e cina
questo uomo di denisova di qui è stato
però possibile sequenziare il dna e
scoprire che anche quello sarà
incrociato con la mostra pensi
in realtà la nostra specie fino a
relativamente poco tempo fa conviveva
con altre due specie umane che erano
queste due e che hanno lasciato qualche
traccia nella nostra eredità genetica
tornando verso nord spostandosi un
pochino verso est
arriviamo in un luogo che oggi è
l'ultimo luogo che ci può raccontare
com'era l'europa prima della glaciazione
prima di 20 mila anni fa
la foresta di dialoghi e già in polonia
queste sono ovviamente immagini di
arresto e non immagini 20.000 anni fa ma
la foresta dei dialoghi esce all'ultimo
lembo di foresta primaria rimasto in
europa e anche l'ultima foresta dove
vivono in libertà oggi i bisonti europei
che probabilmente 20.000 anni fa erano
una delle prede fondamentali di quelli
che erano i nostri antenati e che sono
praticamente scomparsi probabilmente per
la caccia da parte dell'uomo
scendendo ulteriormente arriviamo nel
caucaso ma qui facciamo un passo
indietro perché non siamo più nella
storia di homo sapiens ma incrociamo un
nodo cruciale e fondamentale lo stesso
perché un milione e 800 mila anni fa un
nostro antenato homo georgij cousseau
forse homo erectus ancora non si è
capito se siano la stessa specie due
specie diverse
era arrivato già nel caucaso dopodiché
si sarà riprodotto per un po avranno
fatto delle piccole dei piccoli
insediamenti un pochino come vichinghi
nel nord america ma non sono riusciti a
rimanerci in realtà tutta la popolazione
dell'europa e homo sapiens però ad
manisi in georgia hanno trovato 4 crani
quasi perfettamente conservati di questo
straordinario mini le che già un milione
e 800 mila anni fa era arrivato aveva
cominciato a colonizzare l'europa se noi
scendiamo ancora un pochino arriviamo in
anatolia tornando indietro lungo la
strada percorsa delle antenate di mia
madre arriviamo in anatolia in turchia
nella parte meridionale quasi al confine
con la siria zona oggi teatro oggi di
guerre tremende e arriviamo bio backlit
e per questo posto è il più antico
centro religioso prendendo in centro
rituale conosciuto risale a circa 11.500
anni fa ed è la prima testimonianza la
più antica testimonianza del fatto che
l'uomo aveva cominciato a diventare
sedentario e probabilmente aveva
cominciato a diventare sedentario
proprio quella stessa zona
perché a poca distanza da lì si è
scoperto queste sono le iscrizioni
assolutamente incomprensibili ancora non
comprese theubet di pepe che è stato
scoperto solo di recente
poco lontano da lì circa 10.500 anni fa
poco prima che l'uomo diventasse
sedentario si arriva all'agricoltura
lì si sono trovate le prime tracce di
domesticazione del frumento monococco e
lì probabilmente ha avuto inizio
all'agricoltura che poi quella che ha
permesso insediamenti stabili ha tolto
il nomadismo falco iniziare il neolitico
come viene chiamato e quindi ha permesso
agli uomini dell'epoca anche di
cominciare ad avere qualche cosa come un
centro religioso o comunque un centro i
periti di cui non conosciamo moltissimo
scendendo ulteriormente lungo la nostra
la nostra
riavvolgendo il nostro il film della
nostra storia arriviamo un pochino più
giù dove c'è il puntino giallo questa è
la grotta di mano a thiene israele e qui
ritorniamo a quella che è quella piccola
parte quella minima parte del dna
dell'uomo di neanderthal che sta nel mio
nel mio dna cioè quel 2 per cento
probabilmente qui almeno così si dice
circa 55 mila anni fa che si
incontrarono homo fa pensiamo di
neanderthal in questa grotta in
particolare
anche in altre grotte in altre grotte di
questa zona del medio oriente sono state
trovate testimonianze di convivenza o
comunque di vita contemporanea di homo
sapiens di neanderthal per cui sappiamo
per certo che in quella parte del medio
oriente homo sapiens e neanderthal
vivevano insieme non si sa se in pace o
meno questo non è dato saperlo però
vivevano insieme ed è lì con ogni
probabilità che si sono incrociati e che
sono rimaste queste tracce del dna di
neanderthal nel nostro dna
ora scendendo più giù non ci sono
particolari altre indicazioni e tracce
del viaggio di homo sapiens salvo il
fatto che nella valle dell'omo in
particolare proprio nella nella regione
di addis abeba nella regione nella
regione etiopica è stato trovato quello
che a oggi alfio antico fossile di homo
sapiens conosciuto e la versione
primitiva di homo sapiens di 200.000
anni fa prima di cominciare la
migrazione uno sa pensa è cambiato molto
anche in quella regione
pare che avesse colonizzato in parte
l'africa soprattutto l'africa
meridionale che abbia attraversato circa
100 mila anni fa un periodo abbastanza
terribile probabilmente per ragioni
climatiche un momento in cui l'uomo era
stato sull'orlo dell'estinzione
in realtà ha poi recuperato la
popolazione umana e intorno a 70 mila
anni fa ha ricominciato a migrare
proprio da questa zona
questa è la storia mia siamo ritornati
alla fine del viaggio e siamo di nuovo
al punto di partenza
la storia mia ma probabilmente la storia
di molti di voi di molti europei
quantomeno perché è molto probabile che
si facesse lo stesso la stessa analisi
del dna avreste dei risultati molto
simili
qui siamo ritornati al punto di partenza
addis abeba e siamo ritornati a un punto
in cui con il racconto della mia
semplicissima storia abbiamo ricostruito
in qualche modo una parte della storia
dell'umanità se volete saperne qualcosa
di più sul progetto genographics
scenografico punto national geographic
punto com
grazie